they say never become too good at
something you hate or they will make you
do it for the rest of your life you ever
wonder I just feel a negative or angry
it's because your input determines your
output the garbage that you listen to on
the radio the trash you see on TV the
bush that you hear from the people that
you hang out with it rubs off on you I
don't know what dream you have but I can
guarantee you there's somebody in the
hospital right now praying begging God
to have the opportunity that you have
right now hello believe nation I'm Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from artist poet
rapper and entrepreneur Prince EA and my
take on his top ten rules of success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always as you're
listening if something really resonates
with you there's a message that really
holds true to you please leave it down
the comments below and put it in quotes
so that other people going to be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
heyyo my whole life people have been
telling me to be realistic is that a
real job or you being realistic listen
realist don't start computer companies
realists don't fight for equal rights in
a town where discrimination is the norm
realists don't get cut from their high
school varsity team and go on to become
the best basketball player in the world
ever realists don't do that
crazy stupid and you got to be a little
crazy if you want to be successful so
don't ever tell me to be realistic I
refuse to accept the reality I was given
I'd much rather create my own a lot of
you guys may not know but I'm a
naturally shy person I know right me yep
been that way ever since I was a kid I
get anxiety I'm nervous to go and
introduce myself to people especially in
you know sometimes to talk to beautiful
women yeah I'm very shy I was scared to
raise my hand in class basically just
fearful of the things that I knew that I
should do ever since childhood and it
still affects me to this thing so I wish
I would have learned this trick back
then because I would have been more
courageous more confident I would have
done more things try more things save
more things that were all my heart but
here's what you do enough talking when
you get that feeling that you want to do
something like talk to someone you're
interested in raise your hand ask a
question or ask for a raise the longer
you wait after you get that initial
feeling the more likely it is that you
won't do that thing that you
really want to do why because your mind
starts to overthink make excuses after
excuses Oh what if I look stupid what if
I get rejected but here's the hack
here's the trick are you ready for it
it's real quick real easy and it works
once you know what you want to do count
down from 5 5 4 3 2 1 and then go and do
that thing that you want to do like a
rocket ship
countdown and then blast-off sounds like
the silliest thing ever but it works it
works based on the science of
metacognition and study after study has
shown its effectiveness see it quiets
the negativity bias that we have in us
the stinking thinking the the blob flies
the worry see worried is a misuse of the
imagination it does nothing but drain us
of our willpower but when you focus on
the countdown you interrupt the worry
the doubts and then you can go and do
what it is you want to do that's it see
you're just tricking your mind
and see this is such a great tool to
help you take control of your life
if start living more authentically use
this for things like waking up in the
morning eating healthier going to the
gym whatever positive change that you
want to make in your life
this will give you the currents to
finally become the truest version of
yourself how much longer are you going
to say one day
gonna just count down and do it now I
didn't invent this this comes from the
amazing Mel Robbins she has a great book
called the five-second rule I just
finished it on audible amazing so check
it out check it out try guys let me know
which what happens what you think and
who knows maybe you can change your life
in just five seconds go
so you fed your final exam you didn't
get the job that you wanted and your
relationship ended painfully
congratulations now before you click
over this video I want to tell you that
I myself have been afraid of failure
practically all my life until I learned
the truth and the truth is as failure is
one of our greatest strengths I mean
success is cool but it naturally builds
the ego arrogance pride and greed but
failure to failure in spencer's to
failure naturally builds humility
self-examination and self realization I
mean failure can bring you closer to God
because spend your teachers have so many
things about ourselves but only if we
acquired enough to listen so don't get
angry because you fail because your
anger is blocking the lesson so you find
your equals new possibilities in life
that you didn't expect and in life you
can't expect anything to go your way all
you can do is put your all into what
you're doing and let go sometimes you
win and sometimes you learn I mean there
are so many stories of successful people
failing over and over again I think the
moral is that if you aren't afraid of
failure and you learn from your failures
you can literally fail your way to
success because the wise men once said
even a broken clock is Right twice a day
if you buy me a gift right like this one
it's a bomb in here you're trying to
play me and I don't take the gift you
try to give it to me I don't take it who
did it blow up on you right it's the
same thing we're hating on somebody if
you're hating on me giving me this
negative energy and I don't get insulted
it blows up on you you feel the pain not
me it's video isn't for haters haters
are not a problem or reaction to the
haters of the problem haters aren't
going away they're everywhere you can go
online and find videos of babies
laughing the housings of dislikes like
who does that only a hater we got
stop reacting and taking this gifts that
they give us that makes us blow up and
the best body armor to protect yourself
from a hater is compassion if you fully
put yourself into the shoes of a hater
how can your head hater
they don't even haters anymore to put
yourself into their shoes they're just
sad people you realize that nobody
psychologically happy you're healthy
could ever hate on someone and I'll
prove it I have hated on people before
and I'm sure you have too we all have
moments of jealousy envy low self-esteem
taking our insecurities out on somebody
else it's human but go back to how you
felt when you did that you were unhappy
so when somebody's hating on you that's
where it's coming from only deep
internal pain could ever make somebody
lash out and do something hateful these
are hurt people and hurt people want to
hurt people and I know it's not easy to
not take this gift I mean it's wrapped
up so nicely you want to debate and be
defensive but you got to remember
there's a bomb ahead don't do it a lot
of people ask me how do I know what my
true purpose is the answer is the
difference between a career and a
calling it's the difference between
satisfaction and fulfillment it is the
difference between an interest and a
passion what is the difference between
an interest and a passion so many people
are interested in this interested in
that but see when you go to marry
somebody you don't get down on one knee
and say baby will you marry me I am
interested in you not know you don't do
that unless you want to get smacked in
the face and then left you got to say
maybe passionate about you you
completely I cannot surely live this
life
without you without us together that's
operating from the heart
and if you don't operate from the heart
I can guarantee you'll live a life
climbing a ladder and if you get to the
top you will realize that it was laying
against the wrong wall they say never
become too good at something you hate or
they will make you do it for the rest of
your life so live ask yourself these
three questions
what are your natural talents what is
something you enjoy doing what is
something that you can't shut up about
you got to read write and talk about it
that's how you get closer and closer to
your mission or purpose in life still
confused ok so I believe that the best
teacher of how to live life is dead
legend has it that when we are our
deathbeds we will be visited by ghosts
these are the ghosts of all ideas dreams
abilities talents given to us my life
and if we never acted on that idea never
pursue that dream never worked on those
skills use our voice over all that book
then those ghosts will say we came to
you and only you could have given us
life
but now we must die with you forever
so ask yourself this question my friends
engaged this thought experiment if you
have one year to live
365 days and whatever you chose to do
you were guaranteed to succeed that what
would you do
chances are that is what you should be
doing right now when you're on an
airplane before takeoff the flight
attendants always says there's an
emergency and oxygen masks will
automatically clear it from you if
you're traveling Wilkins out or someone
who requires assistance you sure your
Massholes first and there's just the
other person see life is just like this
before you try to go and help somebody
else you got to first help yourself you
got to secure yourself some people may
call it selfish but if you're painting
and hyperventilating in life and you
trying to go and help somebody else I
don't care how good your intentions
chances are you're both not going to
make it see there's a reason they say
secure your mask first before helping
even children that's how important it is
for you to be stable first because once
you're stables then you can help the
child you can help the old lady the old
man the teenagers what I'm trying to say
is that in life to be the most help to
others you got to take the time to
secure your own mask to secure yourself
financially mentally physically and most
importantly spiritually that means you
gotta leave friends family turn off the
game the award shows and just be with
yourself because see in the operating
room ain't no visitors allowed no guests
no friends no family
why
because the patient is undergoing the
transformation well in that same way you
must get by yourself if you want to
transform into your best version but let
me finish with this after you have your
mask properly secured and you're able to
breathe it becomes your obligation your
duty to help others secure their mask so
ain't nothing wrong with being selfish
in the beginning but make sure the end
game is to be selfless because to be the
only one breathing or to play while
everybody else is our conscious will
surely put you on a crash course for
loneliness and disaster every day we
allow and even encourage people to dump
garbage into our minds and into our
lives too contrary to popular belief you
don't just consume nutrients through
food by way of your mouth you also
consume through your eyes and through
your ears you ever wonder why you feel a
negative or angry it's because your
input determines your output the garbage
that you listen to on the radio the
trash you see on TV the bush that you
hear from the people that you hang out
with it rubs off on you
everybody talks about GMO stay away from
GMOs will stay away from the human GMOs
that the greedy the miserable the
obnoxious these people are toxic they
drain you they complain they remind you
of your mistakes they tear you down they
gossip they aren't there for you when
you need them and some of these people
are even in your family but these aren't
necessarily evil people that just
trapped in a cycle themselves but that's
their problem not yours
you can't fix them you have to fix
yourself and become an example for them
so politely just give yourself some
space from these people or else you're
going to end up just like them you keep
hanging out with losers you're going to
wind up picking up the qualities of a
loser hang out with people that
encourage you would empower you to
become the best version of yourself you
deserve that you deserve to be happy you
deserve to be you so figure out what you
want out of life because you're going to
be the only one with you for the rest of
it life is short and it's a wise woman
once said fake friends negative friends
ain't nobody got time for that
I read a study yesterday it said that
last year more than half of us actually
chose not to take our full vacations
from our jobs question don't you think
it's crazy that so many of us go into
work even when we don't need to be there
times we could be on the beach buried in
sand or traveling the earth we spend it
in the office traveling from desk to
desk buried in paperwork see in this
chaotic world everything goes so fast
we're so busy seems like everyone's
middle name is multitask but now before
you go and act all holier-than-thou how
many extra tabs do you have open on your
computer right now we all need time
let's get away from the race for our
family friends for the sake of our
mental state time to rewind recharge and
reconnect not reporting to the office on
emails that should be on redirect
because life ladies and gentlemen is all
about moments no one in history has ever
been able to hold on to one not a single
soul and you never get them back
see
that one goes no do-over no 3y no DVD
ruin you can skip to a previous scene
ask yourself how many trips did you
almost take how many sites that you
almost seen how many moments if you lost
thinking about the next one digging that
once you get this okay get there maybe
that will be the best one life is caught
leave it or we will ever have now but
let me be perfectly clear I'm not saying
it for your child even though I know you
deserve a six-month vacation twice a
year
how about we lost em fortress with long
dancing from no distractions spend time
with family instead of co-workers
meditation instead of aggravation for
replace our screen savers with the Sun
rises to Palm Pilots with the palms
freeze Sam copy machines with and I
really hate Jam copy we cease
the most precious thing we have in life
our moments let's make the most of them
before they disappear let's see the
world while we still can and sewer
stones while they're still here because
when our lives are almost over it won't
matter how much money we made or hours
we worked or sometimes we got employee
of the month
but we will look back on other memories
we made the hours we spent with those we
loved and to where we father of the
month
mother of the year friend of a lifetime
holidays three of time where we go away
come together now all let's take a whole
vacation and be fully present creating
memories and will last forever one of my
favorite stories is about a man this man
is walking down a path and finds an egg
an eagle's egg he takes this egg and
puts it into the nest of a backyard him
pretty soon the Eagle hatches with the
chicks and grows up with them now all
his life that Eagle did what the
chickens did he would poke around in the
dirt looking for worms and insects to
eat he would fly if you feed it to the
air like chickens do he cluck around
this time past that eagle he grew very
old and one day he saw something above
him
just staying it it glided gracefully and
majestically through the clouds what's
that the eagle says oh that that's an
eagle one chicken responds
he is the king of all birds the master
of the skies but we belong to the crown
because we watch his chickens don't
worry about him you will never be mad
and that ego lived and died a chicken
because that is what he thought he was
this new year
it's time to take flight you and me both
know that you don't belong where you are
right now you don't belong with some of
the people you around right now you got
no business doing what you're doing
right now you're being a chicken when
you were born an eagle so now the
question is how long is it going to take
to make the decision to make this shift
and show some courage show some
character lean 10 where characters funny
you know character is the ability to
carry out a resolution long after the
excitement of the moment has passed
let's say that again some of y'all might
have missed it character is the ability
to carry out a resolution long after the
excitement of the moment
are you going to say you wouldn't want
to do something do it for two weeks and
then quit like you did last year like
you did the year before last you say you
want to lose weight get in shape get
your business off the ground get closer
to God and then turn around and party
get live drink alcohol eat like crap and
continue to live below who you were
created to be thereby committing the
greatest sin known to man no no no no no
I'm not I'm not religious but I'm gonna
take you to church watch this see the
word sin watch this see the word sin
comes from the Greek word sin used in
archery it means to miss your market the
greatest sin in life is to miss your
mark to not be who you were created to
be to be a chicken instead of an eagle I
don't know if you guys remember growing
up the story of Icarus
you know a lot of people remember Icarus
being this guy who got the wings made
out of wax his father cautioned him not
to fly too high or the Sun will melt
your wings and what happened
it was Icarus arrogance that caused him
to fly too high Sun melted his wave and
boom fell to the earth dead but that's
not the full story no no you you didn't
know there was more to it the Icarus his
father also cautioned him against flying
too low
he said don't fly too close to the sea
or your weight will cause you to plummet
into the water see we all know not to be
too arrogant to all most of us but how
many of us know not to be too humble to
meet too timid too shy too safe
[Music]
it is says that the greatest tragedy in
life is not that people aim too high and
miss it is that people aim to glow and
hit I see a lot of people on Facebook
everywhere Instagram talking about the
friendzone hi laughs he's in the friend
zone
lifting the hover hang but I don't see
too many people making jokes about the
other zone the comfort zone
ain't no means about the hey no jokes
you know ride because a lot of y'all in
there well in this new year let's step
out of our comfort zone fortune favors
the bold and it is the cave that you
fear the cave that you fear that will
hold the treasure that you desire
we get a new year's resolution forget it
let's make a new life resolution to be
fully and authentically you I don't know
what dream you have but I can guarantee
that there's somebody in the hospital
right now praying begging God to have
the opportunity that you have right now
don't blow it it is time it is time to
go from mediocre to meteoric it is time
to go from being counted out to being
counted on it is time to fly like the
Eagle you are or do you want to continue
to clock with the chickens I don't care
who you all will race with age with
gender I don't care about any of that
stuff but what I do know is that you
have a dream inside of you in that dream
you have kept hidden from the world
you made excuses for it you delayed it
you've listened to people telling you to
be realistic but deep down in your heart
you know that you're not living to your
potential and life is now something
you're just getting on with I want to
lay some some reality on you real quick
where is the wealthiest place in the
world do you know it's not China it's
not Dubai it's the graveyard because in
the graveyard you will find inventions
never invented business is never erected
songs never songs books never written
ideas never nurture people never
realized because it was scared to take a
risk
scared like you
but you want to know something else
you're not in the graveyard yet and
every we get one life all right
and every passing moment we would never
get back again you would never start
this video with the same perspective you
had when you click Play
you would never brush your teeth the
same way twice in your life ain't no
rewind button no life
[Music]
I will never get that breath back ever
again see this present moment is so
precious we have to be here we have to
be in it and make the most of it we have
to live our dreams now because they are
possible 6000 years ago man created the
wheel only six thousand years ago a
written language was created six that's
it and if I may remind you the airplane
is only a little over 100 years old
there was no internet 50 years ago no
cell phone so don't sit here and tell me
that everything that they can be done
has been done when we haven't been here
for very long there are dreams their
their ideas and accomplishments that are
waiting to be discovered that are
waiting for you
Helen Keller was once asked what on
earth will be worse being born blind she
said it will be so much worse to be born
with sight but no vision why can't we
have cures for every disease known to
man why can't we have clean water food
education for every person on this
planet why can't we have peace on this
planet why don't we have to die to go to
heaven the earth is already in space we
can have heaven right here right now
just a shift in this why not
because somebody said it's impossible it
can't be done I'll tell you this there's
never been a statue erected for critic
everybody tell you how to do it they
never did it moral of the story is do we
you be you and be here now your dreams
are pasta obsessing over these
celebrities Kim Kardashian you live your
life step into your greatness they say
the average person dies at 25 when it's
buried at 75 know what that means unless
you figure it out
don't let this negative world get to you
don't let it win do not go where the
path may lead but go where there is no
path and leave a trail
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Marcus mocha
kala asked me to if there's someone you
like me to profile in the next top ten
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what was your favorite message
from this video what did you learn from
this video that you're going to
immediately apply somehow in your life
or in your business please leave it down
the comments below I'm really curious
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Brandon from 1% better
Brandon thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word doing
the review on your YouTube channel and
posting it to Twitter as well I really
really really appreciate the support man
and I'm glad you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
there was a study done on 300 world
leaders everybody from Martin Luther
King to to Gandhi to Helen Keller you
name it you know what they found they
had in common 75% of them we're either
raised in poverty had been abused as
children or had some serious physical
impairment see these individuals knew
they became great because they knew that
life isn't about what happens to you
it's about how you handle what happens
to you and you can either break down or
break records your choice so your mind
is out of control you want to control
the mind well guess what you can't do it
nobody can do it trying to control the
mind is like trying to flatten out water
you just make more waves because that's
the nature of the ocean it has waves it
has crashing you don't say there should
be no waves in the ocean well the
natural state of the mind is full of
thoughts mental noise and once you
accept that the easier it will be to go
beyond it because you are not the mark
you have a mind but the problem is you
have been identifying with the mind with
your thoughts for your entire life if
you are the ocean why would you identify
as a way it's just a way well you are
that which observes thoughts stop
identifying and stops it's just a
thought and what is every thought made
out of now
you bring it to life with the attention
you give it see every single day we have
fifty to seventy thousand thoughts but
the ones that stress us on the ones we
keep putting our attention on but these
thoughts don't have any more strength
than any other stressful thoughts come
like a knock on the door and you keep
letting them in are you saying no no I
don't want you to come in no no no stay
out and that makes them knock even
louder
so both aversion and attraction see and
multiply thoughts the secret is just
don't mind the mind know that this is
the natural state of the mind don't feed
it you do that by not trying to control
just hold your ground and the thoughts
will go away this is the law of the
universe everything passes just stay as
the observer of thought don't touch them
don't resist the thought label it or
create a whole story around the doll
just stay as the pure awareness this is
a much higher place your true place in
silence so ya adults will arise and you
feel them yes you're going to feel them
but they will pass you don't have to
follow them anymore down their rabbit
hole just remember it's just a thought
don't touch it
just stop and fix your attention in that
silence nothing more very simple you
don't have to fight control or defeat
the mind just stay as you are how simple
as that just stay as you are as the
silence in between two thoughts and the
mind will dissolve by itself into the
nothingness that it really is your
whatever it is you're going through I
want to tell you that you are exactly
what you need to be you see this this is
a lotus flower some say it's the most
beautiful fragrant flower on the face of
the earth but the funny thing is it was
born out of the nasty dirty ugly swamp
the swamp the mud you know grow lotuses
on marble or in the highlands only from
the mud and this beautiful flower
emerged I want to tell you that you are
the Lotus all of the ugly situations the
your past the struggle the strife is
necessary you need these situations
to force you to become what you were
destined to be which is greatness so
hold your ground
keep moving forward out of that mud I
promise you that you will get through
and all of that ugliness the struggles
the strife will make your victory speech
that much more beautiful